et allez besoin d'un câlin nous ne sommes pas un câlin et la
famille est sacrément droite ce film est livré
avec de gros billets de grandes
séquences d'action
et nous avons de la chance de travailler avec
des coordinateurs de cascades fantastiques il y a
des cascades de voitures massives qui tournent et des
voitures flippy nous poursuivons  les
rues de Moscou, c'est mieux que de
tourner sur un plateau, c'est tellement réel
que c'est mieux que vous fassiez exploser quelque chose dans
ce film d'accord, mon personnage
suit rarement les règles et utilise simplement
tout ce qui est à portée de main pour l'essai
promis, la poursuite en voiture est incroyablement
et  l'action est épique
toi